sign tonight Halloween a very dangerous
time for our pets chocolate toxic to
both dogs and cats but that is not the
only threat a look now at Halloween
hazards and the symptoms you need to
look out for if you think your pet has
gotten into those treats
every Halloween trick-or-treaters return
home with all sorts of goodies great for
the kiddos but you should never share
these treats with your pets not all
candy is the same it has a lot to do
with is it chocolate or not chocolate
what else is in it there are several
Halloween hazards pet parents should be
most concerned about the first chocolate
it contains ingredients that dogs are
much more sensitive to than people white
chocolate not as toxic as milk chocolate
dark or semi-sweet chocolate but no
amount is safe and if your dog displays
the following behaviors contact Animal
Poison Control signs of chocolate
toxicity would be things like
hyperactivity muscle Tremors and
elevated heart rate gastrointestinal
upset vomiting and diarrhea and in
extreme cases they can even have
seizures candy corn and other
ingredients in candy such as high
amounts of sugar and fat can cause
severe stomach upset for dogs and it too
can be fatal grapes raisins and
raisinets also a problem it only takes
us small amount to poison your pet these
items can cause kidney failure in dogs
candy wrappers can cause serious
problems as well with intestinal
obstructions dogs can sniff out all
these sweet treats so place them into a
cabinet they can't get into or an
airtight container and if you have any
concerns if your dog has eaten any
amount of Halloween candy call your
veterinarian or call animal poison
control
another thing to note keeps sugar-free
gum away from your pets it contains the
artificial sweetener Xylitol which is
also toxic to dogs